take this that's yours now
that that's an omega and that has a moon
phase see that moon in the bottom that's
yours that's yours you see the moon on
the bottom of it you see that this is a
happy man right now that's my watch
that's my favorite watch by the way do
you see the the moon in the bottom of it
yep that is the actual moon phase it's a
real
high resolution photograph of the moon
and as the moon rises it will rise is it
set in the position where the moon is
currently oh that's awesome [ __ ] yeah
it's awesome take that piece of [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] frisbee you got on your
wrist
you can't you can't get this back
because you just did it on records it's
yours man
this is a steampunk watch the [ __ ]
robot thing writes it and erases it
every minute that's so dumb
but that watch that watch is my favorite
watch and i want you to have it joe
thank you my pleasure
you have a big ass wrist yeah
i do well we can get it sized for you no
no this is perfect but uh [ __ ] man do
you see the little moon thank you so
much you see it at the bottom wait until
it comes full moon you get a real sense
of what it looks like it's beautiful
it's a beautiful high resolution image
and one of the reasons why i like omegas
first of all the astronauts that went to
the moon allegedly they uh wore omegas
but uh also it's a it doesn't have the
same sort of cachet value as rolex's or
a lot of like the a lot of like the
people that have a peripheral
understanding of watches yeah but
they're [ __ ] phenomenal watches they
make amazing watches i have a bunch of
omegas i love them but that is my
favorite watch and you have my favorite
watch now
joe thank you actually this is the one
thing i think a watch could add his
perspective on our like the cosmic scale
that's why i like that watch and that's
why i think you should have it because i
would look that watch and i would say
this is where we are right now with the
moon cycle yeah and when it comes full
moon like right now it's just kind of
like a little it's probably a quarter
moon or something like that yeah yeah
well when it comes full noon you'll get
a real sense
of what it actually looks like because
it's beautiful it's a beautiful high
resolution image of the moon with like
little stars behind it
see how much [ __ ] connor got for his
watch this week yeah but that's what
ridiculous ones that's ridiculous i
don't like those watches i mean look you
could like whatever you like yeah that
that's a million dollars his watch
that's preposterous it's all filled with
diamonds and [ __ ] i don't own a single
diamond i've never had a diamond in my
life i don't want a [ __ ] diamond i
like
engineering that's what i like i'm a fan
of engineering and what i like about
that watch is the engineering behind it
is that there is a mechanical watch
meaning the time is kept within like a
second or two
i don't know what it is like a day or i
forget what it is but also with a
complication this is crazy complication
that shows the moon rising across and
when the when it goes dark and this i
know when i can go outside to see the
stars because i look at my watch and
when my watch shows me no moon that's
when i go outside on my deck
because when i go outside of my deck i
know i'm just gonna see nothing but
stars and no moon at all no light
pollution just beautiful stars in the
sky
i'm gonna take care of
take care of it my brother take care of
it